I have the pleasure to introduce two of
our very own students undergrad etoro
attack attackpa and graduate student
Sergio Iran Cantu
they will guide us in a reflection on
the Life and Legacy of Dr King
over here first from itar and Then
followed by Sergio
good morning everyone
my name is etoro atakba I'm a junior
here I'm studying mechanical engineering
with a concentration in product
development and as Lulu said I'm your
undergraduate speaker for this program
also I want to thank you all for coming
out before I jump right into the speech
so thank you all for being here I'm
really honored to present to you all
today
it's been three years since I sat in my
makeshift study and press submit on the
series of documents that were supposed
to somehow represent my character my
ambitions and my potential
I was 16 and I had labored for hours
stamping permanently onto a page
intentions and goals that today
I have not met because my expectations
for what I would grow to consider to be
my crowning achievements at MIT could
could have been based in no sense of
reality because I in reality didn't know
what MIT was
MIT is the mecca of innovation and
Technology yes the absolute greatest
place in the world to receive an
engineering education yes a space to
conduct Advanced research and meet
genius professors and students yes
but when I take a moment to consider
what has really shaped my experience and
been Monumental in my growth here it
hasn't been the revving arms of robots
which don't get me wrong I do love but
the warm arms of the community I've
built
over these two and a half years I've
been constantly switching out and
reorganizing the pieces that construct
my image of MIT
and I want to show you all that this is
not just an Institute but a place to
grow in your morals and your leadership
wide-eyed and anxious in the classic
freshman way in the fall of 2013
I did in a manner of speaking something
that could stop almost anyone in their
tracks
I met MIT students
yes indeed the most profound moments in
my experience here have been the
conversations that I had not with
professors or advisors but with the
fresh-faced 20 year olds who I happened
to run into in the dining hall before
the talk Dustin 630 study sessions
the young men and women who wore their
pajama pants because they were that
comfortable with me sharing experiences
that completely floored me and left me
grappling for a way to take action
I have although not been able to fulfill
every eager promise on my application
had the opportunity to do something
remarkable
I've been able to listen to my peers
tell me about their deepest insecurities
they're qualms with the Institute
I remember one day about a year and a
half ago wanting to tell my close
friends who had been called the n-word
and told that they don't belong here
something to the effect of that couldn't
have happened at MIT
but it did
and things just like it have happened
again and again I've heard my Spears
speak about feeling unwelcome on their
own campus afraid to speak up in class
for fear of getting the answer wrong and
thus perpetuating stereotypes about
feeling invalidated in regards to how
race and gender have etched persistent
obstacles into their experiences told to
let it go and move on
about having been told throughout their
lives that they aren't supposed to be
smart and subsequently not forming a
relationship or fearing their own
intellect
about being told that they don't look
like they go to MIT or realizing that
MIT makes them no different from the men
and women who have been victims of
profiling and police violence
about feeling abandoned unfit
underrepresented and without key
resources
so many times we've laughed helplessly
and held hands asking each other
rhetorically how we can possibly achieve
complete academic focus when faced with
so many problems Beyond just the ones on
our psods
MIT is not just an Institute because it
hasn't just given me an education in the
traditional sense
MIT introduced me to the people who have
infected me with their passion for
building a stronger community in a more
inclusive society and inspired me to
acquire positions within the black
students union the black women's
Alliance in order to work towards
bettering Campus Life opportunity and
our understanding of each other
unfortunately because I have held these
positions I can say in a personal
connected sort of way that in this past
year in particular we have truly
improved our level of discussion as a
community on race
although we have certainly spoken in
some capacity about diversity and
equality in the past
we've been more deliberate in engaging
the variety of sub-communities and power
levels
than at any other time since I've been
here
we as undergrads have been able to
compose a strong list of recommendations
we have faculty staff administrators and
students have been able to form a
Sisterhood
and share our stories Through My
Sister's Keeper
we as a community have been able to
maintain a dialogue through ask a black
person and other organized discussions
that level of impact makes me extremely
proud of the MIT Community especially my
peers who have stepped up and had the
courage to spearhead many of these
efforts and to get so many other people
on board
it is for this reason that I can say to
my MIT to my peers in the MIT Community
one thing that I know without a doubt
about them
you are a Contagion
you are everything they say you are in
the books and the movies your words have
this power to hold Like Glue on the mind
that takes them in and then compel that
mind to take them it to share them and
spread them
and this is a power that like all comes
with great responsibility
I challenge you to infect others with
your voice
the voice is in your head don't have to
be as silent and personal Affliction
they should be an epidemic on the
grounds of our campus
because you are the Revolutionary you
are the difference
and I know from experience that once
someone catches wind of your emotion and
listens to your thoughts and ideas the
virus of your voice is chronic and
incurable
the greatest recent example of this is
the aforementioned list of
recommendations which is now received
backing from the academic Council
the list was made possible largely
because we have been able to speak
amongst ourselves consistently to the
point where we all through our own or
through others experiences have this
Mutual knowing of what our challenges
are here at MIT
we all can say in one United voice that
we need representation and mental health
and that we need faculty that truly
values the well-being of the students
and that we need diversification of our
departments and that we must teach our
students at least some basic knowledge
about the institutions of racism and how
they are harmful to the growth of our
society
thus as an undergrad who is in some
sense at least representing some of us
here today
I want to invite you all to our table
and what I mean by that is I want us to
further this trend of the kind of
conversation that made the list of
recommendations possible
I want us as the entire MIT Community to
be deliberate in taking our discussion
about diversity down from the emails to
the types of everyday conversations that
we don't have to suit up for or be
careful about
the kind that my peers and I have at the
dinner table in Mccormick were the
tables in the house to kitchen or the
big round table in the BSU Lounge
where we don't have to navigate so
carefully that we miss some key points
or sentiments
everyday conversation especially when it
transcends the boundaries of Faculty
staff
student
administrator
has the power to lend you an enormous
amount of perspective an amount that's
completely unparalleled by anything with
a header and a salutation
here at MIT we lead in innovation
we lead in research we lead in the
financial and Career Success of our
graduates
and now it is time for us to lead in
action
to set an example for our peer
institutions on how to conduct
community-wide diversity and inclusion
efforts
as MLK once said the function of
education is to teach one to think
intensively and critically intelligence
plus character that is the goal of true
education
we cannot allow The Institute to exist
without a without making a deliberate
effort to develop this kind of character
to encourage the facilitation of the
conversations that we continually avoid
on account of discomfort
if we truly want continued progress we
have to learn that we are not at the
mercy of discomfort
we are not at the mercy of discomfort
and we must learn to overcome it
we must learn how to look directly into
someone's eyes when we say or listen to
something like people don't feel wanted
here
we have to explain and hold accountable
we have to learn how to listen to others
misunderstanding of our of our
sentiments without shutting down
because in my case for instance growing
up in a Nigerian household and going to
a subpar public Georgia high school and
having separated parents and having some
relatives who went to MIT before me and
some who never made it out of the
village
all of these things matter
but we have to be proactive in helping
each other to understand why they matter
this is the only way to identify and
address the resources that are missing
here
I say to my peers
speak
about what can be done better
speak about how community life can be
improved speak and others will follow
suit because you are a Contagion
infect with your voice and not every
idea will be gold but every idea has
validity and Power
we must all speak
because we've still got a long way to go
here at MIT
thank you